now that we know a little bit about the
convolution integral and how to apply
some Laplace transform let's actually
try to solve an actual differential
equation using what we know so I have
this equation here this initial value
problem where it says that the second
derivative of y plus two times the first
derivative of y plus two times y is
equal to sine of alpha T is equal to
sine of alpha T and they give us some
initial conditions they tell us that Y
of zero is equal to zero and that Y
prime of zero is equal to zero and
that's nice and convenient that those
initial conditions tend to make the
problem pretty clean but let's let's get
to the problem so the first thing we do
is we take the Laplace transform of both
sides of this equation the Laplace
transform of the second derivative of Y
is just s squared this should be a bit
of second nature to you by now it's s
squared times the Laplace transform of Y
which I'll just write is capital y of s
minus s so we start with the same degree
is the number of derivatives we're
taking and then we decrement that every
time minus s times y of 0 you kind of
think of this as the integral and you
take the derivative one so this isn't
exactly the derivative of that - you
decrement that one you just have a 1
there Y prime of 0 and that's the
Laplace transform of the second
derivative now we have to do the Laplace
transform of 2 times the first
derivative that's just going to be equal
to plus 2 times s Y of s s times the
Laplace transform of Y that's that there
- Y of 0 and we just have one left the
Laplace transform of 2y that's just
equal to plus 2 times the Laplace
transform of Y and then that's going to
be equal to the Laplace transform of
sine of alpha T Laplace transform of
sine of alpha T we've done that a
multiple multiple times so far that's
just alpha over
s squared plus alpha squared now the
next thing we want to do is we want to
separate out the plus transform of Y
terms or the Y of s terms actually even
better let's get rid of these initial
conditions Y of 0 and y prime of 0 is 0
so this term is 0 that term is 0 and
that term is 0 so our whole expression
and all I can get rid of the colors now
is just becomes a pick a nice color here
becomes s squared times y of s plus 2 s
plus 2 s y of s that's that term right
there plus 2 y of s is equal to the
right hand side is equal to alpha over s
squared plus alpha squared now let's
factor out the Y of s or the Laplace
transform of Y and so we get s squared
plus 2 s plus 2 all of that times y of s
is equal to this right hand side is
equal to alpha over s squared plus alpha
squared now we can divide both sides of
this equation by this thing right here
by that right there and we get Y of s
the Laplace transform of Y is equal to
this thing alpha over s squared plus
alpha squared x or you know I could just
say times 1 over s squared plus 2 s plus
2 I could just say divided by this but
it works out the same either way now
what can we do here remember we I was
doing this in the context of convolution
so I'm probably I want to look for a
Laplace transform that looks like the
product of two Laplace transforms I know
what the inverse Laplace transform of
this is I in fact I just took it it's
sine of alpha T so if I could figure out
the inverse Laplace transform of this I
could at least express our function y of
T at least as a convolution integral
even if I don't necessarily solve the
integral from there it's just calculus
or if it's an unsolvable integral we can
just use a computer or something
although you can actually computer to
solve this so if you might skip some
steps is even going through this but
anyway let's let's just try to get this
in terms of a convolution integral so
what can I do with this
this is let's see this isn't the perfect
square so if this isn't a perfect square
the next best thing is to try to
complete the square here so let's try to
write this as a so let's see if I write
this as s squared plus 2's plus
something plus 2 right I just rewrote it
like this and if I wrote this is s
squared plus 2's plus 1 that becomes s
plus 1 squared but if I add a 1 I have
to also subtract a 1 I can't just add
ones arbitrarily to things if I add 1 I
have to subtract 1 to cancel out with
that one so I really haven't changed
this at all I just rewrote it like this
but this now I can rewrite this term
right here as s plus 1 squared and then
this becomes plus 1 that's this term
right here is the plus 1 so I can
rewrite our my whole Y of s is now equal
to alpha over s squared plus alpha
squared x times 1 over this thing s plus
1 squared plus 1
now I already said I know what the
Laplace I know what the inverse Laplace
transform of this thing is I know what
the inverse Laplace transform of this
thing is now I just have to figure out
what the inverse Laplace transform of
this thing is of this this let me pick a
nice color of this blue thing in the
blue box and then I can express it as a
convolution integral and how do I do
that I could just do it right now I
could just immediately say that Y of T
let me write this down Y of T so the
inverse is equal to the inverse Laplace
transform of obviously of Y of s let me
write that down Y of s which is equal to
the inverse Laplace transform of these
two things the inverse Laplace transform
of alpha over s squared plus alpha
squared
x times 1 over s plus 1 squared plus 1
and now the convolution theorem tells us
that this is going to be equal to that
this is going to be equal to the inverse
Laplace transform of this first term in
the product so the inverse Laplace
transform of that first term alpha over
s squared plus alpha squared convoluted
with convoluted with I'll do the little
convolution sign there I was about to
say convulsion they're not two different
convoluted with the inverse Laplace
transform of this term inverse Laplace
transform of 1 over s plus 1 squared
plus 1 that's all if I have the product
of two things Laplace transforms and I
can take each of them independently and
I can invert them the inde the inverse
Laplace transform of their product is
going to be the convolution of the
inverse Laplace transforms of each of
them each of the terms of each of the
terms and I what I just said confused me
a bit so I don't want to confuse you but
I think you get the idea I have these
two things I recognize these
independently I can independently take
the inverse of each of these things so
the the inverse Laplace transform of
their products is going to be the
convolution of the of the of the each of
their inverse transforms now what's this
over here why this is at the beginning
of the problem this the inverse Laplace
transform of this right here is sine of
alpha T sine of alpha T now and then
we're going to convolute that with the
inverse Laplace transform of this right
here
let's do a little bit of work on the
side just to make sure we get this right
so the Laplace transform the Laplace
transform of sine of T is equal to is
equal to 1 over s squared plus 1 that
looks like this but I was shifted I was
shifted by minus 1 right you might
remember that the Laplace transform the
Laplace transform
of e to the 80 sign of T when you
multiply e to the 80 times anything
you're shifting its Laplace transform so
that will be equal to 1 over s minus a
squared plus 1 and now we have something
that looks just we essentially shifted
it by a so now we have something that
looks very similar to this if we just
set our a to be equal to negative 1
right here's our a is equal to negative
1 then it fits this pattern this is s
minus negative 1 s minus negative 1 so
the inverse Laplace transform of this
thing right here is just e to the a
which is minus 1 so minus 1 T times sine
of T times sine of T so this is the
solution to our differential equation
even though it's not in a pleasant form
to look at and we can if we want to
express it as an integral I'm not going
to actually solve the integral in this
problem because it gets hairy and it's
not even clear that well I won't even
attempt to do it but I just wanna get
into a form and from there it's just
integral calculus or maybe a computer
let's see so this is equal to what's the
convolution of these two things it's the
integral from 0 to T of sine of the
first function of t minus tau so it's I
could rewrite I could write this well I
can actually switch and I haven't shown
you this but we can switch the order
either way but actually let me just do
it this way so it's sine I could write
this as sine of out t minus tau times
alpha I'm taking the sine of all of
those things times e to the minus tau
sine of tau D tau that's one way that if
I want to express the solution of this
differential equation as integral I
could write it like that and it actually
should be kind of obvious to you that
this could go either way
because when I wrote it when it was a
product up here obviously a product is
is I can the order does not matter I
could write this term first or I could
write that for term first so if I if the
regardless of which term is written
first I could take the this
the same principle would apply and I'll
formally prove it in a future video so
we could have also done it the other way
we could have written this expression as
e to the minus T sine of T convoluted
with sine of alpha T and that would be
equal to the integral from 0 to T of e
to the minus t minus tau sine of t minus
tau times sine of alpha tau D tau so
these are equivalent either of these
would be an acceptable answer if you
have a test where and normally on a test
like this the teacher won't expect you
to actually evaluate these integrals the
teacher will just say get it into an
integral just to kind of see whether you
know how to convolute things and get it
actually get your solution to the
differential equation at least into this
form because from here it really is just
I will say basic calculus but it's non
differential equations so hopefully this
other this the second example with the
convolution to solve an inverse
transform clarify things up a little bit